No necesita ser presentada, es la empresa
más grande, más admirada y más exitosa
de todo el mundo. Cada minuto factura más
de 400.000 dólares y su facturación anual
supera los 215.000 millones de dólares.
Nunca en la historia una empresa había sido
tan admirada, había crecido tanto o había
ganado todo este dinero. Sus numerosos son,
sencillamente, colosales.
Su inversión en I+D es casi tan grande como
la de toda España …
y el dinero que gana cada año supera a lo
que ganan países como Emiratos, Kuwait, Irak
o Canada con la venta de petróleo. ¡Im-presionante!
Sí quieres comprarla, prepara la cartera,
para hacerte con ella vas a tener que poner
sobre la mesa más de 750.000 millones de
dólares.
Tal cual, es tan grande que prácticamente
ningún gobierno del mundo podría comprarla.
Hablamos como no, de Apple.
Pero, como se dice aquí, en VisualPolitik,
esperad un momento, porque en este vídeo
no vamos a hablar de Jobs, ni del Iphone 8
ni de ningún tipo de Ipad.
En este vídeo vamos a echar un vistazo a
la dimensión, a la influencia, a la estrategia,
a los beneficios y también a los problemas
de Apple en su conjunto.
(LA DÉCADA INOLVIDABLE DEL IPHONE)
Hace 10 años, el 29 de junio de 2007 Apple
lanzó al mercado el Iphone. Es justo que
nos paremos un momento aquí porque, amigos,
el Iphone ha sido uno de los productos con
más éxito de la historia.
(En apenas 10 años se han vendido cerca 1.300
millones de unidades de este teléfono inteligente.
Y Apple ha facturado con ello, ojo al dato,
más de 800.000 millones de dólares, hablamos
por tanto de uno de los más grandes negocios
de la historia de la humanidad.)
Pero no penséis que su influencia se limita
a ello, para nada, El Iphone ha tenido un
impacto descomunal en nuestras vidas, y…
también en muchos sectores de la economía.
Fijaos, el legendario Steve Jobs dijo del
Iphone que era algo así como unos tres productos
en uno… y la verdad, se equivocó por completo.
(El IPhone, y los teléfonos inteligentes
se han tragado a montones de productos y sectores:
reproductores mp3, cámaras de foto y de vídeo,
gps, relojes, alarmas, calculadoras, radios,
etcétera, etcétera.)
Sí, podemos decir que el Iphone ha sido la
peor pesadilla para muchas industrias.
Fijaos en estos datos, porque reflejan muy
bien lo rápido que cambian las cosas.
(Desde que Apple lanzó el Iphone la venta
de cámaras digitales ha caído casi un 70%;
la de Mp3 un 87%; la de GPS y sistemas de
Navegación un 80% y la de cámaras de vídeo
un terrorífico 93%.)
Vamos que aquí el concepto de “destrucción
creativa” se aprecia en toda su dimensión.
Eso sí, al tiempo que todas esas industrias
se han venido abajo, otras han surgido con
fuerza. Hablamos claramente de los desarrolladores
de aplicaciones y también de nuevos modelos
de negocio como Uber, Spotify o Wallapop.
(“Sin el Iphone los creadores de Sotware
serían mucho más pobres. Las aplicaciones
que desarrollan para estos teléfonos les
generan más de 20.000 millones de dólares
al año”). The Economist.
Pero hasta aquí, todos conocéis perfectamente
el Iphone, los Smartphones y todo lo que han
supuesto. De hecho, 1 de cada 2 personas que
estáis viendo este viendo lo estáis haciendo
desde un teléfono inteligente.
Así que, vayamos a la primera pregunta clave
¿Qué le ha supuesto realmente a Apple toda
esta impresionante década de éxitos?
(UNA MÁQUINA DE HACER DINERO)
Mirad, amigos, cada vez que Apple presenta
resultados, hay un momento, un instante en
el que tienes la sensación de que el mundo
se ha parado. Y de repente, boom, explosión
de reacción y titulares… de todos los tipos
y colores.
(Qué si el resultado es histórico, qué
si el crecimiento no es el esperado…)
(Pero por encima de todo, si tomamos perspectiva,
no podemos olvidar que Apple es el mayor negocio,
la mayor máquina de hacer dinero de toda
la historia empresarial.)
Como os dije en el vídeo que hice sobre Amazon,
cómo no, aquí en VisualPolitik, por cierto,
os dejo el enlace en la descripción y también
al final de este vídeo, para saber si una
empresa gana o no dinero, dinero de verdad
contante y sonante a mí me gusta fijarme
en el dinero que realmente entra y sale de
la empresa.
Pues bien ¿sabéis qué? El caso de APPLE,
sencillamente, no tiene precedentes.
(Tan solo en los últimos 5 años la empresa
ha generado, después incluso de descontar
el dinero que ha dedicado a inversión, a
I+D o a comprar empresas, la sorprendente
cantidad de 250.979 millones de dólares.)
Y es que, amigos, Apple logra casi el 90%
de los beneficios de toda la industria de
teléfonos inteligentes.
Es decir, como os comentaba antes, muchas
petro-monarquías del golfo pérsico no dudarían
ni un segundo en cambiar el negocio del petróleo
por uno como el de Apple.
Pensad que solo esta compañía es capaz de
ganar más dinero que Kuwait, Qatar o Emiratos
con todo el petróleo y el gas natural. Es
de sobresaliente.
(Y sorprendentemente Apple no ha despilfarrado
todo este dinero comprando a diestro y siniestro
empresas a precio de oro, algo muy común
en los mercados financieros. ¡Para nada!)
(Apple compra una empresa cada 3 o 4 semanas,
pero a diferencia de lo que suele ser habitual
elige muy bien sus objetivos. Compra sobre
todo Start-Ups con nuevas apuestas tecnológicas.)
Pero claro, puede que os estéis preguntando
¿Qué hace Apple con todo este dinero? Pues
básicamente ahorrar y premiar a sus accionistas.
(Apple tiene en sus cuentas bancarias más
de 250.000 millones de dólares, la mayor
cantidad de efectivo acumulada nunca por una
empresa que cotiza en bolsa.)
(Y, por otro lado, en los últimos 5 años
la empresa se ha gastado la friolera de 180.000
millones de dólares en premiar a sus accionistas.)
Sé que es fácil perderse con estas cifras
tan grandes… así que para que os hagáis
una idea os diré que tan solo con el dinero
que tiene ahorrado Apple podría pagar íntegramente
todo el presupuesto de la NASA en la próxima
década.
O en otras, palabras, si se lo propusiese
Apple podría llegar antes a Marte que el
mismísimo gobierno de los Estados Unidos.
¿No está mal para una sola empresa, verdad?
Ahora ya podéis entender por qué Apple tiene
una valoración tan alta en el mercado y por
qué hasta el mismismo Warren Buffet, el inversor
más legendario de todos los tiempos, ha decidido
apostar por esta empresa.
(EL NUEVO EMBLEMA DE EEUU)
Hubo un tiempo en que los coches de la General
Motors, las películas del oeste, los bancos
de Wall Street, o las hamburguesas de McDonald,
fueron los emblemas de Estados Unidos, la
muestra de su prosperidad y su poder económico.
Hoy, amigos, ese puesto le corresponde, claramente
a Apple.
Ojo, sé que algunos estaréis diciendo…
¡Pero si casi todos sus productos se ensamblan
en China!
Es verdad, pero, su tecnología es “pura-norteamericana”,
algo que por cierto se encargan de recordar
en todos sus productos. Y esto, tiene un efecto
claro en la economía:
(Se calcula que Apple ha creado directa o
indirectamente 2 millones de empleos en Estados
Unidos, trabaja con cientos de proveedores
en el país y ha impulsado el surgimiento
de nuevas actividades empresariales que han
puesto a Estados Unidos a la cabeza tecnológica
del mundo.)
Tal vez, el mejor ejemplo de todo esto es
el peso que Apple ha logrado en la mismísima
China, la gran potencia adversaria de Estados
Unidos.
Solo en este país, Apple facturó en el último
ejercicio más de 48.000 millones de dólares,
una cifra mayor que todos los ingresos de
Coca-Cola en todo el mundo.
Claro que no todo es de color de rosas…
(LAS SOMBRAS EN EL UNIVERSO APPLE)
Precisamente algunos de los grandes quebraderos
de cabeza para los ejecutivos de Apple proceden
del lejano oriente, especialmente de China
y la India.
En China, a pesar de las cifras en bruto,
lleva más de un año viendo caer sus resultados…
(Entre otras cosas porque Apple parece estar
enfrentada con Tencent, la empresa propietaria
de Wechat, la aplicación china por excelencia
que lo hace casi todo y que puede estar preparando
su propio smartphone.)
El caso es que a pesar de los esfuerzos que
está haciendo Apple le está costando encajar
en el mercado chino y eso desde luego es un
problema.
Por ejemplo, la retención de Apple entre
los usuarios de Iphone supera el 80% en Estados
Unidos o Reino Unido, por ejemplo, mientras
que en China es del 50%.
Por su parte en la India, que se espera sea
el mercado que registre mayor crecimiento
en los próximos años, la presencia de Apple
es como decirlo… marginal. Apenas tiene
el 3% de cuota de mercado. Aquí la compañía
está intentándolo todo, pero de momento
las cosas no marchan del todo bien.
Y luego, amigos, está la dependencia del
IPhone y las fuertes expectativas que siempre
genera Apple.
(Hoy por hoy el teléfono supone casi el 70%
de todos los ingresos de la compañía y hay
quien se pregunta ¿Es que Apple ya no sabe
innovar? ¿Qué pasaría si mañana se produce
una disrupción tecnológica en la industria
y el Iphone pierde terreno?)
Y,para colmo, 2016 fue el primer año en que
Apple vendió menos teléfonos que el anterior…
Y eso para una compañía acostumbrada a crecer…
Pero para ser justos, todos estos son problemas
inevitables en un mercado competitivo, y desde
luego la posición competitiva de Apple hoy
por hoy sigue siendo excelente.
Tal vez lo que pasa es que esta compañía
ha situado muy arriba el punto de exigencia
y nos ha malacostumbrado.
(“El iPhone 7 lleva a Apple al trimestre
de mayores ventas de su historia”. XatakaMóvil)
Y, además, no podemos olvidar que, para una
empresa tan grande, crecer ya no es algo tan
sencillo.
(¿Y QUE PASA CON EL FUTURO?)
Si algo ha demostrado APPLE hasta ahora es
que es una empresa que sabe hacer las cosas
bien.
Probablemente ninguna empresa es tan seguida
de cerca y tan continuamente evaluada como
lo es Apple por las decenas de miles de seguidores
incondicionales que se ha ganado con el paso
del tiempo.
Bueno pues a pesar de ello, la sensación
es que mejor o peor la empresa siempre cumple.
El caso es que frente a lo que pueda parecer
todo apunta a que Apple tiene una estrategia
marcada que sigue contra viento y marea.
(En primer lugar, seguir mejorando el Iphone
sin grandes disrupciones por ejemplo con la
realidad aumentada o la inteligencia artificial
de Siri.)
(La idea es convertir al Iphone en un gran
cerebro para un ecosistema de gran valor.)
Un ecosistema, amigos, que comienza con los
propios servicios vinculados a sus productos:
Apple Music, icloud, la App Store o Apple
Pay.
Esta última por cierto una de las grandes
promesas de la compañía. Según muchos analistas
Apple sueña con convertirse en todo un intermediario
financiero y que Apple Pay venga a ser algo
así como una nueva VISA… quien sabe.
Y ojo porque esta “división” de servicios
es ya la segunda de Apple y la que más crece.
Cada año genera más de 25.000 millones de
dólares.
(Luego está la expansión de los complementos
que dependen del propio terminal, como el
Apple Watch o los Airpods. Y aquí las cosas
tampoco le están yendo mal, Apple se ha convertido
ya en la mayor compañía de güerabols -de
dispositivos corporales- del mundo.)
En esta línea, muchos expertos dan por hecho
el próximo lanzamiento de gafas inteligentes
y nuevos sensores y dispositivos, por ejemplo,
para la ropa o los accesorios domésticos.
Y como tercer pilar, está lograr que sus
productos se integren en las cadenas de valor
industrial y profesional. Por ejemplo, en
hospitales, despachos de ingeniería o fábricas.
Es decir, complementar su línea de consumo
con unos bienes de capital.
Hay que decir de esto se viene hablando hace
tiempo, pero los resultados hasta ahora sido
un tanto decepcionantes.
1, 2 y 3 pilares. Junto a ellos también está,
no podía faltar claro, lo que podemos calificar
como la búsqueda de la innovación disruptiva.
(“De vez en cuando, viene un producto revolucionario
que lo cambia todo”. Steve Jobs.)
Así es, Apple tiene ya una división trabajando
en el futuro posterior al iphone.
Entre sus trabajos está el llamado proyecto
“Titan”, para desarrollar aparentemente
una plataforma de transporte autónomo…
Veremos.
(De momento en Apple parece haber muchos proyectos,
la empresa ha contratado a muchos diseñadores
y profesionales de diferentes sectores; y
sus ambiciones son grandes… pero de momento
la dependencia del Iphone es total.)
Amigos, solo el tiempo podrá confirmar si
Apple consigue o no mantenerse en primera,
de momento todo lo conseguido es impresionante.
Y, además, cultura, recursos y experiencia
le sobran a esta empresa.
Turno para ti ¿Eres más de Android o de
iOS? Dejanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo no te olvides de
darle a like y suscribirte al canal.
Por cierto, si quieres saber más sobre Amazon,
échale un vistazo a este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.